hello
i'm andy terrell i'm here to talk to you
a little bit about model review
and kind of my my journey of taking a
model from exploration to production
um you'll be able to find more of my uh
details of my talk
over on the uh this
github uh link a tarot slash model
review talk where
you'll have the super notebook and an
example uh model review
notebook and a few other things i'd like
to thank some of my
co-authors in this um andy maloney and
john hanley uh
provided a lot of material i'm
presenting today and the rex data team
has been
gracious enough to deal with me
pestering them and getting
their feedback i'm
like i said i'm andy terrell i'm the
chief data scientist at rex i'm also the
president of
focus an organization dedicated to
helping the pi data ecosystem
both thrive and survive all right with
that said let's get into the talk
so your model is done you're ready to
explore the bright
blue ocean in front of you you've built
this perfectly
wonderful ship
this is i think in this case is a a
reconstruction of an
old ancient ship and you're going to go
and prove to the world your worth
but do you really know what's ahead of
you have you done this before
what is going to happen at this point
what's out there in that blue ocean and
that's where we want to start that's the
perspective we want to take today
we're not necessarily in this particular
i'm talk going to go through all the
techniques you use to
to build a model or all the like cutting
of the corner or explainability or all
those details which are really awesome
i'm really concerned with your models
done
how the heck am i going to sail it
across the ocean so the other view of
this
is if you're handing your off model off
to somebody else what do i expect you to
know
once you give me the model okay
first off there was this great paper by
the some folks at google in neurowips in
2015
on the hidden technical debt in machine
learning systems
and you notice here that the ml code is
that really small part
in the middle there this is a little
black box and
this picture gets thrown all over the
place and i think it really shows kind
of the
the challenge that uh modelers
actually have and that all everyone
talks about the modeling we
love the detail and modeling but to
actually build a full system
you have a lot more resources going into
the the ecosystem
i liken it to the body right like you
have a brain
it's not as big as you know the rest of
your body
you have a heart as well that has to has
to be in order for you to your system to
survive the same with ml code
it's whether it's your brain or your
heart you need it to to work
but it's not the only system to actually
be functional
so let's dive into a little bit about
knowing some of these things
in order to do so let's chart our
journey we're going to understand a
little bit about deploying models and
how they are used in different
production environments
i'm going to track how to track data
into and out of your model i think
something that i see a lot is people
will assume that they have perfect data
coming into their model
and assume that the thing coming out of
their data will be perfect which is
rarely the case in
in practice and then we say how do you
detect problems with your model
especially if you're detecting them
in um in situ as it
happens in the in the world um and then
we'll put it together a checklist so
that you can kind of
dive into it after the talk and kind of
understand and maybe apply it to your
own teams
all right straight away you gave me this
beautiful
handcrafted model that was
perfect recreation of something and i'm
gonna put it in a box
that's right we're gonna containerize it
and
just like you put you know ancient items
and all sorts of wonderful things into
these boxes and ships
it protects them and puts them in in the
um
the cargo hold and everybody doesn't
it's safe and
but nobody has to know anything about it
well that works sometimes but
models are a little bit different than
just 12 factor apps that
are have all their configuration and can
be deployed anyways
so let's go through some of those
differences and just realize from like
the
operations standpoint they like shipping
boxes they don't really want to ship
your
on your handcrafted model they they just
want to give me the square box they can
stack them
and then get across the ocean so how do
we come together with that
well first i'll just talk about data
collection because i think that's like
the first thing that's
way different than your most your
applications are
deployed um how are you
defining your data sources i think i see
these uh
these these shipping containers that
have like you can hook up
water and electricity you better be darn
right that they
they they have potable water and
non-potable water is going to be hooked
up to it they're going to have
the type of electricity whether it's 220
volts or 120 volts or
whatever it is there's some
specification for hooking these things
up to like the life support system and
the same thing exists
in your model are you hooking up to
something like an application database
or the pain of my
my uh behind is the customer relations
management records
all those things where the sales people
enter details all day and
of course there's never any errors in
that data as i mean humans are
perfect right um or then there's maybe
the even
something i hate even more is the web
analytic events where
it's like oh tell us exactly what
happened on your website so we can
optimize every last
eyeball that ever ever came all those
things are great
they come in different formats and
different ways of thinking and you have
to have
some contract that that gives you an
idea of where this data is coming from
i like to talk about that in the
relevance of data providence
uh the pardon the rendering here so
providence is basically um
you showing the entity activity and
agent relationship inside your model
and here's a a a nice tutorial from don
juan
and if you go to his pro python short
tutorial and
here in this case he wants to show the
data
and the person who developed an article
so we have this article
now employed an employment article v1
it was written it was by
this person who was attributed bob
and it was using this uh oes
oe sem 11 st zip file which has the prov
type
of data set and a label of employment
status
so yeah it's a little clunky to like
kind of
read but you can use prof
and the python great python prop tools
to build up data
sets and in in some of my code i'm not
going to show it here
but what i'll end up doing is i'll have
a whole bunch of data sets especially as
they
are i use etl and different data sets i
can
track back to what transform
what extraction methods did i use to get
to that data set
and so getting that provenance and like
entities
activities and agents together to
actually show
how your data came about and that way
you also
inside you can from my data set if i see
my source
came through with ip addresses and at
some point
i strip those out with unique
identifiers to anonymize them
i can go back and see what piece of code
or what
item was actually doing that and then i
can also audit make sure it does happen
because you don't want to keep privacy
in your ecosystem and having provenance
is
a really good way to automatically
generate these contracts and also
show the world what data's coming into
your model
um just kind of reiterate the entity any
physical digital concept
activity something that occurs often the
activities like my script so the entity
will be my script
the activity will be like some
processing peeps and the agent's usually
the person who's
responsible that code whether it's my
team or whether it's
some other team but but generally that's
kind of fall into my my ecosystem
all right so now you need you built this
model
um and you did all the providence you
extracted the data
but you need to test what's coming in
just because you haven't described
doesn't mean like it's actually
what's going to happen so like you test
your contract
and so one thing that's really
interesting to me is like we find
all these wonderful features about a
model such as the range the distribution
some sensitivity factors but then we
throw it away in production
i mean often you'll see people just like
oh yeah i'll just take some
some function and just take whatever it
says and like predict back
like this is like oh you know warning if
you don't know where your model's in
and out of sample you can get into big
errors and if your model gets used
incorrectly you're you're really doing a
disservice and
that communication of what is in and out
of a sample
can't be done through just you know
simple scripts of
throwing an exception or an error if
it's called the right way and you know
what these things are so encapsulate
those range of features
and those sensitivity measures though
and additionally when we talk a little
bit about modern systems you can then
encode these even further up
and have a way of having the monitor
check am i actually in sample did i ever
go out of sample in my last
a week of run and so on and so forth
the other thing you kind of need to take
in advance when you're like
producing a model and you're reviewing
models how is this model going to be
called
there's different ways different people
use them i'll go through a few
uh kind of common idioms here in a
minute but
the way you get called also will define
your sla so if
you're being called on an ecommerce
website for example
and you're in the checkout flow i
guarantee you you will not have
20 seconds to answer your question
now you might you might not you might
have more than you would in a finance
world where you only have eight
milliseconds maybe on
a digital trading platform but you don't
but you you have to kind of figure out
what is the right approach
um i think that typically you know some
numbers will keep in your head you know
37 milliseconds a refresh rate on your
computer
uh the 150 milliseconds is usually the
the time you need to respond to a web
web uh
request to stay active on the page um
but then eight seconds is
um what you might need if you were
actually um
before the the user leave so if you're
gonna do some sort of scrolling thing
you actually can have a little bit more
so the interactivity versus um scrolling
and then if you're like can't meet those
requirements how do you get to
something that's more of a back-end
serving mechanism or something and then
how do you monitor all this how do you
know that you're actually hitting all
this so you need to put that in the
model like
what what are the points that i'm going
to benchmark against and
where and how do i know that i'm hitting
those points
usually through some sort of logging
okay
so how do you get called this is a great
kind of book
software architecture pattern from mark
richards a nice little thin book from
o'reilly
and i love giving this to my new new
hires
just to give them a sense of what's
going to happen to
their model in production now
this is just one of the many things in
here but this is your standard
client server request pattern i have a
bunch of clients
web browsers typically if you're in an
api uh they have some
interface usually http um and then
there's some like for example protocol
in this case he says rest
grpc is a great protocol graphql is
another protocol
a lot of different protocols these days
and then you have your service
components
and then the inside the service
components of the different little
modules the way i usually build
models like my model is one of those
modules
but you could imagine using a whole
model server and it being the rest
piece in the server component and so so
knowing how you're going to get called
will inform this now in this case like
if you're a user interface layer using
rest and you have an eight
an eight minute response you have to
know that most uh clients uh
web browsers are not going to pursue
keep keep the connection open for eight
minutes
sometimes you you'll catch different
places that might do something but there
are like built-in timeouts on the
internet that
cause you to to lose those requests and
so forth so right away
if i'm in this paradigm i might have two
minutes to respond on
the average request for the average
browser
um but really in actuality they should
be more than like 150 millisecond
uh range 400 milliseconds in order to be
what people expect as a responsive web
page
all right the other place you might get
called is another really common
architecture and this is from a figure
from map
r that details the lambda architecture
which is a
really standard architecture you see in
a lot of places
in this architecture you have three
different layers you have the batch
layer here at the top which is really
your hadoop and you can do things slowly
but you can do all night you can you're
taking in
a large data data lake or
data bank whichever word you like um
and you're computing things on that in a
batch mode so if it takes
an hour to run your your job that's
probably
okay but you always have to worry about
scaling and things like that so in this
case
you're running lots of things on a job
and so you're getting called with
with much more than just one data point
so it's not like
i get one data i haven't come out so
your model can maybe could do
multiple batches maybe it can do a
prediction on a larger frame and then it
speeds things up
so in that that bachelor environment you
really changes some of your prediction
behaviors and you can take advantage of
that in different ways
then we have the serving layer which is
really kind of the layer that's actually
uh being um going to be called
during the the other web ad web
view or the answer on um
a real time view that happens during the
the
application um and then that you can
that's where we could use the other
paradigm is the client request or you
could just
grab the data out of the aggregated
batch view somehow
and then you have your speed layer which
is really just like
very simple aggregation type data um
a good example is in ad targeting you
might have
some counters that tell you do i am i
frequency capping this user so you just
have like an id and the number of times
you've shown
um some display ad to a person
and go from there so really in this
your model can land in any one of these
layers and the
way it gets called can can actually
impact the type of methods you can use
so the speed layer you're not going to
be able to do um
you know deep learning for example of
the batch layer
you can take advantage of the multiple
prediction aspects of it you can do
things like matrix factorization and
keep that factors um across a very large
view so it just kind of
changes the nature of how you're being
called you need to kind of
put that into your specification of your
model and and
kind of the the objectives that you have
okay so here's like
an example from from that i've deployed
at one point which is like
on my node what do i actually have to
model and so even though i have the
model here
like i still have several things going
on inside
my instance and in here you see i have a
load balancer going to
a gateway instance going to my data
model
and you we do that so that the gateway
can take care of like all the kind of
different
crux and challenges that might come
through the model do this as rate
limiting
such as user login credentials things
like that
and then we can have the data model
separated in this lower box
and even in there we we throw on like a
some web servers and proxies in order to
make sure that the data coming to the
model is actually the right data
um and inside of that we're talking to
things like
rds which we'll maybe put in our our
calculators for our cash so that you
don't actually go call the model
or and then in top of that all the logs
will go up to this
box at the top of the paper trail which
is our logger
and we have our little other red boxes
here it says red scope which is the
pinger making sure that our model's
still calling so
having some little health check or
something that says yes this model is
still producing
the right data um is great by using
something like health
run scope one trick i've always used in
the past is to
just run my uh my different uh
just record what's coming in and out
through that rds and just
rerun it and see if things are changing
on my model
often because the data is coming in from
different sources very sometimes you'll
end up
with some some movement in your model
and you can
find that out by just replaying old
old requests and whatnot then i have
things like syngrid which will
email me if something's going really
wrong and roll bar which is a
system that will capture errors and
sentry is another good example
and it'll categorize all the errors that
happen in the code so
even in that model like there's a lot of
different things i'm capturing errors
i'm capturing logs i'm capturing
the model um output coming through
and and i'm actively pinging the thing
just make sure that it's doing the right
thing and checking its temperature
so all those things really help but then
you're out
in the wild and you say like how did i
get here you're being handled the model
and that person needed to give you some
details
and and know that you're actually no
longer in that handcrafted boat
reconstruction from the 18th century
you're actually in uh an icing vessel
studying climates uh so very
very different idea still a boat still
floats still has
all kinds of sorts of bells and whistles
but you kind of need to know what
environment you're going to be in
so how do we do this in practice how do
we get there
so we usually build our data sets
through these
extract transform load objects and i'm
just going to briefly go over a few of
them and then i'll show you
a a a fuller kind of
rubric that we use in our notebooks um
so we
so this is so we have like an extractor
and in this extractor you have different
types of extracts
and so we actually do this kind of
registration protocol where i can
just call an extract on anything and all
you have to do is implement this
underscore extract
and i can kind of build data sets from
all sorts of different types of
extractors i built
same thing with transformers um yes
maybe i
should so in our transformer it's just
taking that data from one form to
another whereas the extractor is maybe
pulling out some elements of that data
and finally we have the load uh which is
loading it in the final form that will
be used for whatever modeling
piece i want and so in that we use this
nice pattern
this shadow pattern that kind of helps
us along
then here's an example of a data set
where a whole bunch of different um
kind of pieces of like where is the data
at how is it
you know how's it stored and so on and
so forth and then this is
uh another coin where the underscore
load method we'll call those load which
we'll call the transform extract kind of
function so we have a nice chain
that tells us all the different places
that data came from
and we can actually pull off a w3c prov
piece from that um
often this is very common you want to
add some sort of caching layer to your
data
um how you add that data whether it's
locally remotely kind of
kind of think through that and and we
extract that into our
to our uh data frame at the highest
level
um and we we can often override kind of
how our
data set will load because sometimes you
have something maybe a little bit
challenging to work through like oh
google analytics has
can only get so many requests a day so
we're going to
batch this over several days and then
and then maybe call the api
or call our um our local copy or
something like that
so you can kind of greatly make that
your life very
simple by using things like these shadow
functions or whatnot
all right so uh here's an interesting
example of an extractor
an iris data which we all love a nice
example that you can kind of play with
and in here we just say load iris which
is kind of your standard um
i think scikit-learn function there
and in this for example we wanted to
only take
a certain number of certain columns the
feature names that we care about
and we want to turn them into like the
iris name perhaps instead of
calling it feature name let's call it
iris name and make it a little bit
easier to use as a
piece of as an example so this is
another
so taking the iris data set extracting
it which was just loading it from
a function in second learn uh changing
out like
which labels we're using and then
turning that into the actual
pandas data frame that we will use in in
model
um yeah and so and here's an example of
that
thing being up all right so we just went
through
how like what we expect to see an
extract load model
and using a few tricks of the trade but
what am i going to when i'm going to
review your model what am i looking for
the biggest one first thing i want to
see is like have you written down
your meta model do i have an objective
do you have a sentence or two that tells
me what your model aims at
because just because it's in code like
it doesn't always translate
super well i'm looking for kpis like
pred what the model predicts
what further actions i need to take to
acquire that data
how to sample predictions that show um
what what would happen in how the sample
prediction and like
how it lights up and then maybe if
there's an outlier
and how do it how does outliers work
inside my model
i expect you to tell me those inputs
just like i did that in the
use that provenance uh extract transform
load
um also can i reproduce that do i have
uh
in an s3 bucket or or some other sort of
storage
spot that i can get to and so forth i
expect you to tell me where my outputs
will go will it be just be
local or standard is it just a uh a
request object
and should i be worried about overriding
some frozen output
next i want to like you know what are my
assumptions about this model like
you know this i have a computer vision
model that sees faces but only in the
winter time
at ski resorts very different model than
uh some of the season only faces
at a beach um
big big glasses make a big difference uh
then you know what are some of the most
common violations assuming the model is
independent or they aren't independent
how can i define some of those
distributions
and do they hold in practice and then
observe data then like we talked about
my sla was determined about where i was
running make an actual benchmark
i you know i always love this wrk
library that
lets you specify how often you're
calling somebody just
test can i keep this up on my server
and so forth is it the best available is
there
better models um or better ways to make
it
faster things like that like you can put
it down
like i didn't make this faster because i
don't really need
uh to be an eight millisecond so i i
kept it in python i didn't use number
that sort of thing um
i think that this is one that's really
challenging as well it's like you need
to have learning curves and
show what is happening are you over
fitting do you get
do you get too quickly to an answer
or does it or did you end up putting
or did your data i guess too quickly the
answer is not really what we want we
feel like we show that there's
uh a very long time to learn like that
okay
your chances are fitting are pretty
great if it's very it's very short then
um you learn the concept in a very small
number of
samples and that's a much better place
to be you can kind of like
show how the different methods you used
have went through that variance
and then you can observe it in practice
like which
how how well am i doing on those tech
like when i get in my
um how my model's actually being called
in practice
in those recordings and that for example
at that rds database
i just run it back over those samples
and see how well my learning and test
curves actually
work on the things that are inside the
the actual um deployed model
then also like we mentioned
show us all your transforms show us how
you're filtering your missing attributes
uh imputation i think is another one a
lot of people don't talk about a lot
like
imputation can change your model by
a lot and we'll show a little demo if we
have time
um and it's important to kind of put
that to use
okay so inside the repo i have
kind of a state like our standard um
version of this rubric i mean you can
see here a title objectives and some
notebook
pieces some details on the data set
generation and all this code that we
kind of just talked over
um i really look for for someone to show
me their
exploration of this data to show me the
the thing that actually
they think this data is going to show
tell us
um and i love to use c board for this
the pair plots really give me separators
if i can get a nice separator there it
um i can tell you like right away like
okay i have a shot with these
sets of features in this case with the
iris data set you can see simple length
but
versus sepa width and you can see very
quickly that there's
some separation and pedal length versus
sepal length
right here and then perhaps there's more
separation over here
between pedal lengths and pedal width on
some of these other
uh some of the other irises so using
these you can
get an intuition of like what's going on
for your traditional models
you can also see there's a lot of other
graphs such as joint plots
um joint distributions uh and so on and
so forth and so in here
kind of pick and choose we just put a
lot in here to kind of show the
different
ideas of what you need to show about
your data
we love to use bokeh in our uh in our
systems
it's a little bit more code to do
everything you want but at the end of
the day like
i will put um well unfortunately
i will put bokeh inside and have a nice
interactive plot
and unfortunately it didn't show up here
but
we'll we'll have it you can execute it
and you have a nice interactive plot
statistics is another great place as
your data comes in
you have some fairly simple statistical
uh
kind of measures such as your means and
your distributions your max
that you can kind of measure not only on
the data you created but this is where
you're going to get
the ranges that i expect to see inside
like maybe the methods that
um check the the
the call to my data so instead of just
calling the model directly with the data
i'll check to make sure that
hey is it actually within this
distribution if i'm coming in and have
some sepal length that's like nine
inches nine centimeters long uh probably
not the right uh
right model for this but that can be
by using such as this describing getting
those samples out i can put that
directly into
the the function that's going to be
calling that
model or i can put it into some wrapper
in that model that
checks all the inputs and outputs yeah
confusion matrix are great
profiling another thing that didn't show
up on this screen
but panda's profiling is really great he
shows you all search like what's missing
and whatnot
um the the next kind of piece i think is
really important is missing profiling
your missing data
because inevitably you will have data
that is missing
you have data that's not going to show
up inside your
um your environment for whatever reason
and you need to be able to handle that
so here we go
through a few like major amputation type
fields um and some papers that kind of
show like what happened how to like
uh handle the different imputation but
one of the the biggest tricks we did
first do is like we just build a little
routine that
here that comes through and just deletes
some data for you
so all right so i deleted my data now i
can come through and profile it again
and do all the same distribution plot so
you see
up above i had this nice rich
implementation
and here's like all the missing data and
you see these things are vastly
different like my separator up here
between steeple length and steeple with
is just
gone um i still have one here with petal
length and
sepal length so even in that like by
taking
a little bit of a caution of like all
right can i delete some of your data can
i change it up
um and see how the distributions change
and then i can come back and so and
here's the the um
the actual the the full data plot for
your example again
um but then if i come and use different
computers what happens
you can see right here that when i
impute from
this uh siebel width versus simple
length and i come with just a simple
imputation
my separators are all kind of all sorts
of
jakey right so that's going to happen to
you in production so how is my data
going to change
and being able to just build a few of
these little utility functions to test
this very quickly is very
very great a really great system to kind
of play with and you
certainly can automate all of this once
you kind of figure out the modes of your
how your model works we like to use
pictures just to kind of get us and so
there's some other things
k neighbors convex convex
optimization and so on and so forth soft
mutation which
is pretty popular um and then we just go
through our model
our you know building our model with
data with missing data with imputed data
show me all of the different ways that i
can kind of play with your model and so
this is
don't have to do all of these every time
but it's just kind of a way to kind of
show it off then what hyper parameters
did i actually
tuned to can i actually bring out those
hyper parameters
and eventually i get down to my learning
curve so i really want to see
how well did that actually actually go
so out of like 120 samples
we really got to the crux of like our
most of our learning done through half
that's a
pretty good learning curve but
you can kind of go back and forth and
then there's confusion matrix obviously
and so forth
all right so that was showing our data
prep showing like all the different
pieces and playing around with the
imputation and so forth
uh you'll be able to find that in the
repo
all right so i'm going to skip this
review checklist um an interest of time
and just talk a little bit about all
right
we went through all the details um you
can go to the repo and see the
the full-on checklist of every item we
just went through um but what happens
when it's down oh my goodness
everything is going to heck i don't know
you know are we stranded or are we going
to be sailing again someday soon
um well that's where the
problem the the product folks or the the
ops folks can really help you as a
modeler in here like you saw this
like we saw the the system that was
built that showed us
all those little monitoring pieces but
then your
your ops folks will have systems like
this and this is a system that
i worked on in the past where my model
was buried deep in this api over here
and then on the other side of this i had
just
you know services around this is just
dashboards and demos and
and so on to kind of play with it i had
an ac tax cue i love to use like
the kafka type um
introspection so if i have something
that's like coming off that needs
more like asynchronous execution i can
just
tap into kafka and see what you know
what happened over the last week
and i can rerun that data and it gives
you a nice way to say all right
it was down oh i can see that all of a
sudden we were out of sample
and we can see where we start getting
out of sample we need to add something
to
to check that in the api for example i
can also see you know my data
um kind of get into your database and
and understand what's happening there
i usually you know kind of keeping both
a redis hot cache for and your database
in the background which is your source
of truth perhaps that
helps you kind of know what's being
written to and read from
and separating those things out but in
getting those caches versus the the
standard layers usually there and then
on monitoring it's funny i always find
that every system i've ever built has
more monitoring tools and it actually
has tools being
used sometimes so everything from like
your log aggregation
to a notification system so if someone
goes down to that polling we talked
about with the
run scope and all you have nice
interfaces you can get into
and understand so you're down but
by building all these elements and
showing your ops folks
what is required to make your model work
they can build in all
of these other systems to help you
whenever it goes down to debug what
what the what's going on in the model
and you certainly learn things about
the the real world that you didn't have
in your training data
once you put a lot of model live
um another popular trend that you should
consider is using um
a model server like bento mlflow redis
ai
and a whole bunch of industry ones have
all kind of come up
and these take away a lot of the some of
the pain of the
the metrics gathering and tracking and
keeping your
latest model up to date and things like
that um
but of course like your mileage will
vary depending on
what your sla can be and so on and so
forth so it's kind of a
investigate each one and kind of
understand what they provide for you
all right that's that's it we
went through a model we reviewed it we
debugged some problems we looked at how
the logging system
uh logging and monitoring systems can be
used inside of it we have
some uh some rubrics and notebooks that
you can like look at afterwards
this talk and i hope you had a good time
and you
your fleet of models can be deployed at
any time and ready to
use in production thank you very much